[Music]
everyone this is Steve entre with glider
and I am here at the Collider media
studio at the Kia Telluride supper suite
in Park City with the people behind
ironbark first of all I want to say
congratulations on the movie you guys
world premiered last night what does
that experience like premiering in a
room with what like a thousand people or
1,200 people
well I quite enjoyed it actually because
we've only finished the film in November
and we've done test screenings but
they're so artificial and there are a
lot there was there was a good
proportion of regular people from the
public in last night there were a lot of
Industry people but and I loved hearing
their responses to film so no I enjoyed
it how was it for you it was really
overwhelming and unexpected you never
know what whole audience would just take
it and from the very first moment as
soon as film started I how audience
reacted I was just amazed by this and
through audience's reaction I was
realizing quality of the film if I can
say that in English like I realized
through their reactions because I
because I'm in a film so I had to you
know I wasn't anyway so I start again so
I'm starting again was a question it was
really really overwhelming and
unexpected and when audience reacts that
way you just lean back and enjoy the
movie and when it was over I couldn't
stay in the in the audience I had to run
out at least for two minutes do
literally ran to I really ran I behaved
really crazy I scared some people who
were responsible for and and I was like
I had to get out of here for two minutes
they're letting me out of there for two
minutes and that was back and then it
started again to be overwhelming because
you're gonna get on stage yeah it was
amazing I mean this is all of our first
Sundance's Sundance first Sundance and
it was it was amazing to just sit in a
room with with people who are here
because they love film and they're here
do nothing but see great films and so it
meant a lot that their response seemed
to be so overwhelmingly positive in the
room it was it was a really special
night very special you know you know I
can tell everyone liked the movie
because I didn't see anybody go into the
bathroom in front of me like everyone
sat in their seats
no one was coughing or yawning like
we're actually a little ahead everyone
watching this interview will most likely
not have seen the movie so I hate asking
the generic question but can you talk a
little bit about what it's about sure
yeah it's it's it's based on a true
story about two guys who were the center
of a who worked to bring information
back from the Soviet Union to the West
and that information ended up
contributing to the end of the Cuban
Missile Crisis and it's so it's a kind
of espionage drama but it's not a
conventional spy thriller because it's a
much more emotional movie it's it's
really about relationships and the cost
of heroism that's what I think it's
about any one hundred percent one of the
things that I really was struck by the
film is that this is not a film that
relies on car chases or gunplay or any
sort of set piece to sell an action this
is about as you said the human cost and
what it really what really went on
behind the scenes can you can you to
sort of talk about that everybody has a
different relationship to patriotism to
what they view as national interest or a
collective interest of a greater good
and it costs something different for
everyone and what I love about the film
is that it follows quite a few people's
very different experiences surrounding
the same event and and we did as Dominic
said there was so much emphasis on the
human factor before we started shooting
the film when we were in rehearsals
Dominick really hammered home the idea
that that in the 1960s everybody had a
very personal relationship to the Cold
War and to the Cuban Missile Crisis
everybody felt it on a daily basis and
nowadays even though we are still at war
we have a somewhat more abstract
relationship to that idea not everybody
not not every civilian knows somebody
who's directly impacted by the war and
and not and that makes it deeply
personal
of all that is different than the way we
might be experiencing something similar
today for my character I'm playing the
film was when we were rehearsing I
remember very well the day that Dominic
told me what it really how it really
might feel to be a hero and you were
talking about the Greek masks and a
mythology and you you performed that
mass somehow in front of me and I never
forget that because it was so much pain
in that so much uncertainty so much of
it was something that was something
between death and life but full of pains
of hero is not that probably what we
think sleek and smart guy who just kills
everyone but which costs you pay which
price you pay for your decision to do
something extraordinary to break the
rule to cross the border and get excited
about that and and decide one day that I
want to be remembered as a hero on every
every cost whatever it costs me I will
do that so this determinate
determination was the first thing that
we were just like I'm intellectualized
in the beginning and the rehearsals and
then it wasn't that was thinking about
it every day but it was sitting in me so
I knew that this is guy who decided to
be a hero but he is in a pain so that
was a human little human touch about
this guy that we don't see necessarily
somebody who is made of iron and has a
strong decisions and she knows what he
does but this trouble of conflict inner
conflict on each step he's taking is was
yeah most important thing to to to build
a character and as soon as character
meets the character of pendeks
Cumberbatch the gravel win and the human
warmth that is sparkles there between
them I think that was just like how
everything that it wasn't about spying
anymore it was just about this two men
playing that in gamba
this incredible game and I speak so much
sorry but I try to answer you Oh one of
the things is you're you're telling a
story that's based on real events but
you're also making a two-hour movie so
talk a little bit about the balancing of
like fact and fiction you know being
honest to what really happened but also
telling I'm making a movie I think if
you are telling a story fiction
fictionalizing a story and drama you you
obviously can't show the whole thing so
you have to compress right you have to
join things together combine characters
combined events take bit out that aren't
central of story but I think you're my
responsibility is the director and I
think I think Tom O'Connor a rather
wonderful screenwriter we felt that you
gotta honor the kind of essence of what
happened so in this movie there are
things that are there characters for
example that are combined and compressed
but actually all the events did happen
and some of them we think happened I
mean we filled the gaps in but I think
if you're true to the essence of the
characters what they did and the events
that's good enough as you say you've got
to get you've got to get it into two
hours you know and that's what I think
my responsibilities your responsibility
has to be to the story in the end you
know for all three of you you obviously
made this on a budget
very clear this is not some huge Marvel
movie so what was it what was the the
thing that you were most for you what
was the thing you were most nervous
about pulling off with the limited time
and money you had and for the two of you
guys did you ever feel any of that
stress of like making you know like not
like you know what I mean like that that
feeling of anyone no I mean no weird you
you know that there's a great production
team behind the film when the actors
have no idea whether our budget is a
hundred million dollars or one this team
made the most of what you said was a
quite limited budget for a really
ambitious film and we would never have
known for a single second if we were
under any kind of constraint at all we
were really given the gift of being able
to do our job to the fullest extent
every day and and it was incredible I
mean
some of those locations did the work of
millions of dollars we shot in Prague
and in London and there are pieces of
those cities that that remain completely
preserved from this time and even just
driving down a certain section of a
street that's been location scouted felt
like it added incredible value to the
film no practical locations are
everything especially when you have
limited money absolutely yeah I mean we
had to create I think it was challenging
to create scale in terms of Moscow at
that time but those things were I think
for me that your most challenging thing
is always schedule with shooting because
you just don't have very much time and I
think I'm naturally quite slow I mean
there are some directors that are just
boom boom boom and I I always need a bit
of time to see what the actors are doing
and to try things
I'm very kind of empirical I need to be
there I've obviously got ideas
beforehand but I and I like the time to
explore an experiment a bit while we're
shooting so for me it's always tricky
however this don't we were only just I
felt like it wasn't like a nightmare
show where we couldn't make we couldn't
make every day it was okay it was okay
but it's always I always think a little
bit more time you can try another setup
you know but also has anyone ever not
said that way I mean if you're on a
Marvel movie you're like we didn't have
enough time and we didn't have enough
money and every day feels rushed and up
against the wire it's really funny
though I just spoke to the guys who did
bad boys for life and they had like 90
million and they said they were
constantly up against the wall because I
everybody takes the every bit of money
they have I think and maxes that
schedule out yeah to just put as much as
they can on the screen yeah but also
there are upsides to the limitations I
mean I've seen it happen over and over
again you're running out of time and
then someone pulled something amazing
out at the back I mean Benedict is
particularly good at that in some ways
he's best ten to six it's like you know
but it does you know there are you
sometimes you know you just want a bit
more time to try something that other
time someone just goes boom because
there's a very good one go right or do
goes or whatever so that it's it's you
know it's part of the art of it making
that stuff work you know I am this is
something I'm always curious about
a lot of directors they want a certain
amount of takes on every setup and some
actors they talk about how their first
take or their second take is when their
have the most energy and some are like I
could do this [ __ ] all day like it's all
good so I'm curious what do you
typically like and for the two of you
how do you do you typically feel like
you got it on the second or third or do
you know what I mean I think you know
what I really like to learn and you can
learn quite quickly like what people's
rhythms are and I often ask if we're
doing close-ups I will say would you
like to go first or would you like to go
second or how do you want to do it
because sometimes actors do feel
strongly other times they really don't
mind some people need a few goes to keep
you know finding things and others are
actually really instinctive and get it
very quickly and they don't necessarily
know that so they might like I can think
of actors who would deliver something
amazing in the first two takes ask for
five more and when you look at what
you've put in the final cut it's always
from the first two so you got to just
watch and learn what what's right for
people I mean and there aren't I mean
some people as well they will do
something one day and the next day it'll
take seven takes you know that's what
the scene is it also changes project
project like I think I used to think
that I was someone who was always better
in my first couple of takes because I'd
had a minute beforehand to focus you
know like if it was a character that was
particularly demanding you know you go
off and you do whatever you need to do
and then you come and you are ready for
that first take but then I did the
marvelous mrs. basil and and it's so
complicated and the rhythm is so
different from anything else I've ever
done and there's so much camera
choreography and background actor
choreography that actually almost never
did we feel like we have it till six or
seven takes in it never happens on the
first take something goes wrong and we
all need that rehearsal on film to get
to a point where we feel great so I love
the opportunity to learn that I'm always
wrong about what I need and and that the
process changes every time because it
means that we're doing things
differently in taking different risks
and that's exciting
well I worked with a couple of arthouse
directors in different countries that
they work
like after 13 steak they start to get
what they want it's hard work but you
learn so much through this and it's
always always different it varies from
the film and project to project with
this particular film I think was just
beautiful how I come from the background
that I was taught as an actor or or
raised or that you absolutely are
devoted to director you don't just
discuss things you just do it first you
first do it and then you discuss it a
directors dream
yeah no I'm not joking it's really my
general attitude is that I I don't know
anything I come is all the plain paper
there's nothing no idea in my head I
might have some ideas but just I I get
most of this stuff from directors and
only they can push me to limits that I
didn't know that I could go that far so
in that particular case what Dominic it
was very beautiful because of we
understood each other from the I think
from the day one that I auditioned I
think there was something that I felt
that we were talking with a same
language or I knew what you were asking
me to do and I I loved it because the
audition felt like it was just like a
rehearsal or you were just playing part
so it didn't feel to cut it short we
didn't do much many takes there was some
some shots were really complicated
because of choreography and camera
movements and you had to do them 20
times and you hate it but and but then
there were the sequences like we showed
the scene I'm not supposed to tell a lot
about the movie no I mean not that story
well every oh no we're not spoiling this
but just the scene with me and Rachel's
character in the film that we rehearsed
a certain way and then you decided to
turn it upside down and I was I can
first moment I was horrified I exist we
did three four takes before and it
didn't work something something was
missing something was missing
and I didn't know what was missing of
course so then you came to me and said
okay forget everything let's do it this
way just this way you
wanna be with them so it just changed
everything it was hard to get there
it took us few takes more additional
takes but I hope we will landed there
where you wanted us to Congrats on the
movie real did pardon me for not knowing
did it is it an acquisition title or is
it does it is it for sale here at
Sundance or yes it is
so yeah I'm confident after last night
that people are talking about it right I
am so not worried about you thank you so
much thank you great job thank you for
having me
and I hope you guys have a great rest of
the festival thank you thank you very
much